alright hi yeah it's great to be back
inta simons and again thanks to the
organizers for organizing another
wonderful workshop so many of the
problems we face in cystic elesta mation
are essentially optimization problems
and they're noisy optimization problems
because we're typically trying to
estimate the minima of Sun function
where we only have noisy access to the
function trickle in so consider the
problem of linear regression right we
want to find the best fit line with
regards to some unknown underlying
distribution and we only get samples of
the function we get n samples and we'd
like to find the best fit line well we'd
actually like to find the best fit line
with regards to the distribution when we
often do in practice we take the best
fit line on the data okay and in high
dimensions this is a question of
estimating a linear relationship with
endpoints and D dimensions and this is
quite expensive if we're going to try to
find the best fit line at a given data
set in high dimensions we never do this
wait this is one you know it's
definitely poly time when n India large
we just can't solve doing your system
exactly okay the things I've been
working on dimensions and the order of
tens to hundreds of thousands and n is
also very big these are problems where
we can't fit our data into memory which
is a headache and you know in small
problems we know how to do this we just
do backslash in MATLAB on large problems
it's a headache and we'd like like this
really is the question we'd like to
automate it will in an automated way
we'd like to do all on these problems
and what makes this problem interesting
is we don't need exact solutions right
because the data is noisy and that
really is the right question here and
that question really highlights a lot of
the trade-offs we face
computation and statistics because you
know at one end of the spectrum what do
we do we'll just do something quick and
dirty like stochastic gradient descent
it's fast it's easy to implement it's
super light on memory we just passed
through our data it doesn't give us all
that good answers but maybe it doesn't
matter that much because the data is
noisy okay the other end of the spectrum
we could burn a lot of computation time
get a very accurate answer is it worth
wasting the extra computation time and
this is really the question so what
would you do here okay and in practice
on these very large data sets by and
large people use SGD I think this really
is the winner okay and I shouldn't point
out this is a very relevant question
right now because there are a lot of
efforts underway to try to automate
machine learning and statistics
algorithms for pretty large data set so
I've just listed a few here these are
sometimes open source packages sometimes
they're private some of these are run by
companies summer universities Berkeley's
is ml based it's open source a very
popular one is VW from jon langford and
one of the reasons this is so popular is
it really has a very good implementation
of various convex optimization solvers
like people have these big data sets
they'd like to get something that works
out of the box and this is pretty nicely
optimized one yes in a sense but they
don't in that be you know they're
definitely not competitive with
backslash and there's a there's a
intuition for that is there typically
used in learning problems where data is
noisy they're like if you actually look
at the numerical answers they're
terrible but the idea is that since our
data is noisy maybe it's good enough for
prediction problems and it's very clear
people want better things because if we
actually look at smaller data sets and
solve things you know very very well
will often get better performance
so by and large these are used because
it's all we can really do on these big
data sets but the question is sort of
related to your question as well that
you know back in the 70s we got these
very nice numerical linear algebra
packages and we don't have to think
about matrix inversion of solving linear
systems and we just hit back / it solves
the problem well and a very nice
question would be can we do something
analogous for artistical estimation
problems where we do things very very
well put them into packages so people
don't have to think about them okay but
to do this very well we really have to
get the details right sort of really to
your question which is you know and it's
very clear the detail here isn't
numerical precision because we don't
care about you know getting the template
of accuracy if an optimization problem
is noisy so the question is how do we
phrase this carefully and how do we
solve this and we'd like to do on every
problem and like the really the goal
here would be you know for basic core
machine learning problems can we
automate them and have people forget
about the details okay so let so what's
our goal well we'd like to do well
statistically do well statistically and
we'd like to do it quickly so again the
problem is we have some optimization
problem lfw we think of lfw as some
expected loss with with respect to some
underlying distribution think of
something like linear regression so
losses the square loss w is a line a
point is just some XY pair okay and we
only have access to this function with n
samples okay but you want to do well
against el of W we don't care about
doing well on the data we see and we're
going to measure ourselves by how well
we do compared to the best so you get n
samples you come up with some estimator
w hat n and we measure ourselves with
what I call the ararat sometimes the
excess risk or regret I'll just call
Tara and this expectation with respect
to the randomness in the training sample
so so this is the setting clear so this
would like to do but we'd like to do on
every problem so this is so let's try to
make a more stringent criterion and see
what we can do the distribution scripts
know if it was a no but we have access
to it from samples that's right so this
is it so that's right so ideally we'd
like to do well with some restrictions
on the loss function but ideally we'd
like to do well on every distribution
but in a sense like look when you get
back / it'll do on on every instance as
a function of condition numbers and
things like that and we'd like something
analogous here so it's basically the one
take-home message from numerical linear
algebra is doing right matrix inverse
when you're solving a system right back
/ because it does all the details
correctly but the point is we want to
get all the details correct it's going
to depend on various properties like
condition numbers and so on we'd like to
do that correctly in the sister
collision but in particular suppose we
didn't have computational constraints
right we would just like to use the the
best fit line so this is sometimes
referred to as interest minimizer at the
M estimator we didn't have computation
of constraints just compute this and
we'd use this ok but this is costly
because you know memory wise it can be a
headache it might be Polly time so that
what we're going to ask to do is look at
the rate of convergence had we use the
best fit line and look at the rate of
convergence of our estimator ok so this
is how well we're doing in comparison to
how we how well we would have done had
we computed the best fit line so the
question is can we drive this ratio to
one on every problem ok so so it's not
just saying asymptotic ram to get the
right answer I want to get the right
answer at the same rate as if I computed
the best fit line now obviously you
could make this ratio wine if you just
computed the best fit line but that's
costly so we'd like to get this ratio to
need to be near one and every problem
where we're mindful of our computational
constraints it is the problem clear
regression listen me so the numerator is
literally how far off the least squares
estimator is from the right answer
because the best residual error and we
compare our best residual error to that
it's exactly that you sure you can put
in out your reg you guys's let's get
back to that you can put nothing ok but
let's just do it for regression is that
good so this is really a setting yep why
are you competing against this
particular ah so if we could do better
than this we would solve a big question
like basically there's a hundred years
of Statistics essentially arguing you
really can't do much better you can
shrink a little but by and put it this
way if I want to measure it mean the
best you can do is use the sample
average you can shrink a little but we
aren't going to try to solve get a
better statistical estimator assume
statistics has told us this is a good
estimator and the reason I'm doing that
is because there is a body of work
essentially arguing the MS tomato erm is
a good estimator ok and now we want to
do well according to this estimator and
this is what people do when they run
these optimization packages they're
trying to compute this estimator so it's
a way to try to phrase this issue of how
accurate how accurate is accurate enough
and we want to do well on every problem
so this is the the criterion its
stringent and notice that you know if
you think about solving a linear system
this is an interesting question because
you know solving linear system is a big
open problem in computer science theory
we're not trying to get bit precision
here we're giving a different criterion
for solving the linear system ok so
that's where we're thinking about this
trade-offs like if we just want to drive
this ratio to one how can we do it so
again
multiplicative versus additive is this a
beginner but let's just literally let's
do this is this is multiplicative bits
on the regret so that's the important
thing okay so it's okay so the main
results are going to be that you can
actually drive this ratio to one you can
do this with a one-pass algorithm the
memory is basically the same as order
one sample the algorithm is trivially
paralyzed able you really can drive this
ratio to one on every problem under mod
restriction see these are problems like
linear and logistic regression various
generalized in your models and this
algorithm is going to have a super
polynomial dependence on the initial air
and by that I mean I logarithms we use
in practice start at a point and you
want to have a very weak dependence on
your starting point so this algorithms
going to crush that dependence on the
starting point okay so in a sense like
yes I said there's trade-offs between
citizens and computation but that's a
bit misleading you really just win here
you can get you can get this in one pass
and there's nothing related to work
that's somehow been forgotten there's a
very nice asymptotic result by judit
skin paul yak but it's a very relevant
question like validity like the last
five to ten years people have been
asking this question over and over again
okay so I'll try to give you a flavor so
the alguns got to be simple right
because you're not holding much in
memory it's really the same complexity
of SGD and you're nailing the problem so
let's see how we do this so it's the
basic outline of the talk is let's just
forget about computation for a moment
look at statistics let's forget about
statistics for a moment and just think
about optimizing on the data we have
okay and then we'll put the two together
so let's just ignore anything
computational right now and let's see
what's the rate of this empirical risk
minimizing so if we compute it exactly
what's the rate of convergence of that
estimator
and again think square loss as the
example we're going to be considering so
these are in a six land they're going to
be kind of the assumptions for local
asymptotic normality so you know so
basically suppose you're measuring a
mean what's the rate of convergence is
the variance over N okay that's
basically what it is here so I'm going
to define this quantity Sigma squared
which is we're going to look at the norm
of the gradient at the optimal point
measure how large it is under the has
seen at the optimal point the inverse
Hessian to find that to be Sigma squared
and the rate of convergence of the
empirical risk minimizer is exactly
Sigma squared over N this is basically
like romero like intuitively it's like
you know if you start at w star and get
a random sample of data so w saw is the
best point you're going to move and if
you did a step of mutant this is how far
you'd be off and this is essentially the
rate of the ERM and the point of this so
there's no computation here but this is
what we'd like to get and we'd like to
get exactly Sigma squared not just 1
over n we this is the exact problem
dependent constant we want is that clear
that's really just you know if we're
doing things right our rate is going to
be Sigma squared over N and we want to
quantify the rate at which that of
course want that to occur quickly we'd
like the constant I could find the 2
Sigma squared over N is also fine but we
don't want dimension or condition number
yeah so the main point is like you don't
want dimension or condition number times
Sigma squared over N and that's where
SGD will get you which is why it's
really quite bad okay we good with
strong coffee aslam's yeah because the
Hessian exists but only locally around
the up yeah so basically these
assumptions for like local asymptotic
normality think regression which is
basically local asymptotic normality
generalizes I think weyni regression so
that statistics we're done it's ignore
it for now that's know everyone it's now
let's switch to computation and for
computation ignore the statistics
problem suppose we just want to optimize
some of convex functions there so before
L was an expectation ignore it for now
let's just think about optimizing sums
of convex functions and there's been a
lot of very very nice work in the last
five to ten years on optimizing sums of
convex functions and the reason this
work is essentially come about it is
because this type of optimization
problem comes up all the time in machine
learning problems and a lot of the work
is how do we get linear convergence for
optimizing sums of convex functions like
optimize it quickly but there's a
question of why do we care about linear
convergence if the reason we're solving
these problems is because they're coming
from statistics problems at the main
point here is you know this is a very
common optimization problem that's being
studied recently and there's a lot of
beautiful work on kind of numerically
precise algorithms for this particular
paradigm and I'm going to cover one
really elegant algorithm by V Johnson
and tongxiang which we're going to
utilize but for now forget about the
statistics problem let's just look at
this particular paradigm let's look at
stochastic gradient descent to see how
it goes wrong and see how we fix it
because that's GD is what everyone uses
ok so let's just start with sgg and and
let's look at SGD for this particular
optimization problem ok we're do that we
want to just optima forget about
generalization we just want to optimize
the sum of convex functions ok so let's
look at SGD it's an old algorithm super
simpler to implement would you do well
each time step so so we're going to
think about fitting this line on this
sample of points so there's no
distribution so what do we do with the
stochastic gradient ascent we're just
going to sample a point randomly and try
to adjust this line so as to better fit
this point right so we stopped at this
point we're going to adjust this line by
moving the gradient so so better fits
that that line right we do that you know
moves actually we do this and we get to
the right answer ok so why is this a
terrible algorithm from a numerical
perspective well suppose you start
at the right answer now you sample this
point SGD is still going to move you
this is terrible from a numerical
perspective this is why the precision is
actually very bad because you're
bouncing around all over the place and
this is why batch gradient descent if
you're at the right answer you don't
move because the gradient zero like if
you actually computed the great iam the
entire function you sum over everything
that gradient zero you don't move but
with stochastic and that's why we batch
gradient descent you get geometric
convergence or linear convergence well
stochastic gradient descent like the
only way you can get this thing to
converge is by turning down the learning
rate and that means your algorithms are
sensitive de learning rates because and
this is really a frustration in practice
because if you you know get things wrong
with setting your learning rates you
really do pay for your mistakes okay so
how do we fix that okay so this is and
again we're ignoring statistic is issue
right now we just want to think about a
better way to implement SGD and think
about why it's going wrong as your
cycling over the data set and you're
turning the learning rate down the
algorithm is converging right and
eventually you should realize you're
doing something stupid right like every
time you're touching this point you're
getting kicked in exactly the same
direction when you're getting to the
right answer and eventually you should
start realizing look the systematic bias
in my algorithm I shouldn't be moving in
the same direction every time I touch
this point and that's really this
beautiful idea of svr G it basically
figures out the systematic bias and this
algorithm takes it out and gets the
American precision it gets linear
convergence it's a very intuitive idea
like if your algorithm is working at all
you should start realizing every time
you hit the same point you're going to
get kicked in the same direction and you
want to remove that bias so this is serg
ok so
let's compute the gradient stages so
let's just start this algorithm as if we
were at the right answer so the first
thing this algorithm the sarcastic
variants readiest gradient descent is
going to do it's going to compute the
gradient at the at some point okay
suppose we started the optimal what's
the gradient at the optimal point zero
so let's ignore the first term right now
yes oh and this thing is zero so what
this algorithm is doing is it's
subtracting out the gradient of the
point you're at with respect to the
gradient of some reference point and if
this reference point is optimal and you
start at the optimal point you don't
move okay that should be clear right
because if I start if wrls is the
optimal point and I start at the optimal
point this algorithm doesn't move
because I'm just basically subtracting
out the grating at the optimal point
exactly we don't we don't know the
gradient at the optimal point we do know
L because where we have the sum of
convex functions always the expectation
guys are saying forget about statistics
for now because there's no way we're
going to get a numerical precision at
sistex problem so for right now forget
about the statistics problem and we're
just trying to minimize the sum of
convex functions yes I really am down to
be out this right so but the point is if
we're not at the optimal point this
isn't going to work because we're
biasing our gradient okay so what do we
need to get SGD that will s GT to work
we need to follow unbiased estimates of
the gradient that's basically why SGD
works so the idea of this algorithm now
is we're basically going to this blue
term is a best guess of the systematic
bias and we're going to subtract it out
okay so we have some w twiddle s we're
going to update that every once and
while the first thing we do is we
compute
batch gradient okay and then at every
sample we get we remove this correction
term and what's the expectation of this
blue quantity 0 right and if W to
twiddle s is and every once in all we're
going to update it so think of wrls is a
best guess at the optimal point we can
take out this blue term because it's
just mean zero we can always modify the
algorithm this way but it has the
magical property that if we're at the
right point this is zero and we don't
move so it's really just intuitively
we're just trying to take our guests of
this bias but we can take it out in a
mean zero way that's the cute trick
because this blue term is always mean
zero so you know the blue terms mean
zero the algorithm is always making
progress because you are following a
stochastic gradient descent and when
you're near the right answer you
basically are moving a lot less ok so
the intuition clear yep
and that's the cool thing it's basically
constant it's sort of a which is which
is nice basically a lot of the
computation is spent here and then you
just take some constant number of steps
so the main point is this algorithm
gives you essentially linear convergence
sort of each update you're cutting your
era down by a constant fraction yes
compared to just using the idiot of the
first step and descending down that day
in the computer cup w turtle is this one
so using which using the gradient
computer of the first step yes under
something down the gradient so you mean
like a batch gradient so this is
constantly this is closely because you
have to pass the data set but you don't
do very often but you do that so I'm
asking how would the w bar s plus 1 yes
radiant from W Twitter less compared to
this w to the less visible oh so another
algorithm would beat compute this
gradient in the first step yes descent
down that video that's missing a batch
Grady in a sense yes and the point is
batch gradient descent is very costly
computationally because every every
update involves passing through the data
set so so the point here I'm not going
with details but this essentially
summarizes the style of guarantees which
many algorithms have achieved over the
last few years which are ways to kind of
amortize passing through your data set
to make progress okay but again I just
want to get to the cystica thing what
about this district irate because we
have to keep the data set memory we have
we still have to pass through it many
times and you know they all we care
about isn't the sum of convex function
is some expectation okay but but this
algorithm basically gets the same sort
of guarantees as these are dual cordon
ascent methods but it's a primal only
algorithm the reason
it is is this primal only because its
prime only is it adapts very easy to the
statistics question so now we're back
everyone two back to the sistex question
we can we care about the expected loss
we can only get one sample at a time so
look it's kind of intuitively clear
there's a reason I present an svr do
rather than cordon in a scent it should
be intuitive appeal the thing to try is
that you just get an unbiased sample of
the gradient this is this is the
modification it's all you do you have
your best guess at the optimal point you
use some number of samples to get an
estimate of the gradient a tell and use
that to correct and note at the
beginning you shouldn't care about
estimating this to accurately because
you're far away from the right answer
but if you knew the right answer you
don't want to move and that means you
had better draw lots of samples here so
it's really two phases what do you do
where you draw a big sample a fresh
sample of points compute the gradient at
that point and use that to correct your
updates and just to run a few more
points again a constant number of
updates and just update and repeat and
every time you go here just increase
your sample size by like some constant
confrontational stage yeah and okay step
when you're passing to the data set
nobody's of computing the loss for the
entire business that's right and if you
did that you wouldn't get linear
convergence because you're bouncing
around and but we can't expect linear
convergence here because it's a
statistics problem and that's why the
analysis is actually quite different
because you know even if you start at
the optimal point you move doing this
but this should be clear it's clearly
single pass because there's nothing in
memory because you're just keeping track
of an average it's trivially paralyzed
abode because pretty much all the effort
of this algorithm is computing this
average
then we'll go through the increasing
this sighs this yes yeah because you
know if you start the right answer you
don't want to move but you have to move
because the data is noisy so the reason
you're drawing more samples is at what
rate oh so you can just use a double x
factor of two so basically that
trade-off determines how fast you kill
the initial error so you can use a
factor of three and you know the low
order term is going to look like n to
the p I just want to wrap up right now
so i just want to point out that
basically just double the tot the sample
size the rate at which this algorithm
convergence is like you know some
constant times sigma squared over N it
depends on the initial error by it's
killing the initial error by end of some
power P which is determined by how fast
you're doubling these things some of the
right thing to do is only increase the
sample size if your gradient looks like
it's near zero I do a hypothesis test on
and then you could even almost get this
exponential but basically the point is
it's a super simple algorithm in one
pass it really does give you Sigma
squared over N times a constant it'll
kill the initial error it is easily
parallelizable because look all the
effort of this algorithm is doing coming
in this step that's easy to paralyze and
this is a constant number of steps out
that you really would do is let local it
because you're so tough think of the
number of others is a function of the
sample size yeah like look I did this
this is a fair statement like it isn't
logarithmic you were actually counting
we're counting things by the samples
just think of a streaming algorithm
every time we touch a point that's what
you can't help your wall
last vid but that's what it should be uh
none of times you're obviously is just
locally you know you're updating that's
the top number of updates of phase one
you're updating gradients here so let me
just come back to that in the question
section but I'll sensitive is the choice
of KS and n in these are super robust
because here you're just doubling see
the main point here yeah the bond chains
with the main point is this this
algorithm is nice because it's a
constant learning rate this is really
what's important in practice it's
working for a constant learning rate the
algorithm is making progress because it
knows it's making progress not because
you're kind of turning the learning rate
down so so I think yeah it you know in
terms of actually putting the packages
you have to set these parameters but I
think there are ways around it by just
doing a hypothesis test let me just take
that to the question section so yeah so
the bottom line is this of these shows
that you should be able to get the rate
of the ERM in one pass and I think it is
progress toward automating our most
basic ml algorithms putting them in
packages this is joint work with a
number of very talented colleagues roy
frost egg is a graduate student stanford
longer is a postdoc with us at microsoft
new england and aaron said ferd is a
graduate student at MIT thanks
so one of the reasons why families this
for Eliza book is because the usual
little dragons are very sparse but here
when you introduce the acceptor your
sort of killing it with the sparsity
it's still paralyzed about these have
points and if you don't you it's
personally to paralyze this thing well
that's one that is already in letting
that in the book where paper sparsely
was one of the main reasons why 23 see
in our speed ups yeah but like that's
the thing this you do you don't need in
some cases pasti can help but here you
can paralyze without sparsity because
it's this is sort of your choice point
to is because most of your time is spent
averaging and not doing the updates
that's why parallelization is possible
can you comment a little bit about
what's difference between doing
something like this verse is just
running like a bash stochastic radius in
increasing your batch size of your
client yeah so so this is a good
question because somehow we don't have
any better guarantees for increasing the
bachelors in a sense this is it's trying
to get a little more second order
information in this algorithm because
it's like a two-point different
algorithm but mini batch really doesn't
buy you much in in these settings and
even in the numerical sense mini batch
even in practice we know this like you
can the best batch size is basically one
in practice like the only reason we do
batch sizes is if it's we have GPS ok
sticking the other questions offline
you